man merkt ihm an ich hatte in den usa
vor einiger zeit eine erfahrung da lag
ich abends im bett im hotelbett mein
handy lag neben mir und auf einmal da
hat dann mein handy mitten in der nacht
dieses geräusch gemacht
was wir hier gerade hören das ist der so
genannte amber alert und dieses geräusch
das geht durch mark und bein denn der
amber alert der ist benannt nach amber
helga man das neunjährige mädchen wurde
1996 entführt und ermordet der mörder
konnte nicht gefasst werden aber wenn
heute in den usa ein kleinkind
verschleppt wird dann schicken die
behörde neben war nachrichten auf alle
handys in der nähe den amber alert den
wir gerade auch gehört haben und
menschen die dann in der region sind die
dann in der nähe sind die sollen eben
die augen offen halten nach dem kind und
sich melden wenn sie etwas verdächtiges
gesehen haben und der amber alert der
hat so seit 1996 mehr als 1000 kindern
das leben gerettet frau schmidt wäre der
amber alert etwas der auch in
deutschland helfen wollte den
deutschland braucht herr zumindest hat
man es im sachverhalte bäcker becker
schon mal diskutiert ob das eine
sinnvolle ergänzung wäre zu den
klassischen maßnahmen sage ich mal
meiner meinung nach könnte es eine
sinnvolle ergänzung sein zu den
maßnahmen wenn man dieses system mit
augenmaß betreibt damit es nicht zur
abstumpfung effekten beispielsweise
kommt also wenn zu oft
fehlmeldung kommen oder der alarm zu oft
geht dann drückt man den gelegentlich
dann mal weg man ignoriert das weil es
vielleicht auch nervig ist wiederum und
dann erreicht man genau das gegenteil
also ja aber mit augenmaß wenn die
entsprechenden rechtlichen grundlagen
vorliegen frau schmidt vielen vielen
dank dass sie heute abend bei uns waren
[Musik]